back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching
all right you guys ready to rock awesome
dude yeah Chen is in a furious mood
today you should be a mountain you
should be one of those volcanoes in uh
in Hawaii Qin no Komachi what Mount
Yoshii Yoshii Mount Korea angry that's
what I think I'm not angry
mad when he has to run the run the ship
again Rick's here no Nick's here but
Derek's gone he's on vacation
also Derek you missed four shows in a
row bro yeah dude who else you're fired
about how black you trying to get there
huh how black you trying to get there
bro anywhere else you for five but
here's the thing he used they're always
the most predominant black excuse used
family reunion I was like okay four
weeks in a row and I had to say the only
families that have family uses that long
are black people and Indian people
that's correct if used to dude an Indian
family reunion two years it'll be at
your local park you'll go there and
you're like what he'll there everyone's
older you're growing crops and stuff
you're like what is rust affari no
that's cool I was in Rastafari at one
time and uh there was a gate like a a
guy was trying to get us to gamble you
know cuz they try to get you to gamble
illegally yeah they're trying to take
your money somehow someway oh somehow
some type of thing and so um this guy
all he would say all weekend was bliss a
bed with me man you know every time walk
my bed with me and he didn't even have a
UH like a book everything he might have
been just had autism you know he's just
on the spectrum oh but if you have the
spectrum down in Rastafari oh then you
you just keep trying to get people to
gamble or like the things you say are
like double down you know looked up so
anyway this guy where's dice just two
rocks oh this guy died actually fell off
of a
I don't want to say like anyway no not
an embankment like a cliff kind of
there's more of a cliff as beautiful
tropical beach but on the way down dude
no joke is like house always wins
[Music]
like do you got this guy gambling with
his own life and he lost good you gotta
set me up with that little spice trader
on cage yeah I have a number should we
send her a picture to you yeah a little
rescue animal yeah yeah you want me to
send a picture you're talking about the
young a young and beautiful very
talented Britney Palmer I saw this lady
right so I remember I was at the quarry
a max Holloway fight where poor a
defeated all odds and defeated max
Holloway oh where you were basically
Dustin Poirier his ring card okay no she
probably saw you there I was like who's
coming for my job [ __ ] is this who knows
[ __ ] with a mullet coming for my job I
brought my own car I had extra rounds
but I was ready for them to go 13 14
overtime and that's when you Trump the
girls they're like old well card only
goes you know yup five not [ __ ] six of
me I had six seven eight nineteen I head
up nineteen round when I had it I was
texting I gotta bring another car so use
but you saw the young well this girl
kept walking around the cage right with
the and I thought she was lost and I'm
like artist chicks lost you know can't
find her seat so she need help being a
good dude yeah I'm trying to be a nice
guy and then I mean you know I was like
every guy at a strip club she I felt
like you know she just kept looking at
me or we connection oh I thought there
was a connection now it also could have
been that I was being a stalker you know
cuz a lot of guys will misplace a
connection for them being a stalker do
you think it's cuz you're the only guy
in the front row with a mullet and
yelling it's not a mullet first of all
it's a long haircut and a lot of you
know a lot of places in the world which
you're not familiar with you think I'm
era you think you just you know the
world ends at the you know how
and America and don't make you make a
sound chin
oh that's chin so anyway but so you you
felt maybe there's a little sparks where
a flying cheese was a roasting yeah and
you think maybe should we send our
picture right now throw it yeah throw
another cheese do you want me to say you
wanna be Harvey you know i'ma send it
yeah I'm gonna say you're trying to get
that dick no don't say anything like how
aggressive should I go so I just sending
go yo my boy yeah my friend thought you
seem like a nice person he saw you lost
at the UFC fight oh my yeah I say my
friend thought you were lost at the last
UFC fight you kept walking around the
ring kept walking around great guy yeah
or just say oh I'll get follow say my
friend was born in March say that be
like elusive yeah I'm just be random but
say hey you into Turtles no man you
don't like that yo you like oh you know
like orange chicken no look at chin made
another sound don't make a bunch of
sounds chin say what you want to say
alright what picture alright just give
me something yeah okay look cool well
that's up to you
Oh see I like that one where's that one
surprised that one side hey that was too
much okay let me do they mean something
no not thinking cuz you're not fooling
anybody
I'm do you this like talking about
sports with the buddy I know act like I
just said something real funny like
laughing like oh no real funny I like
like you just said lot lizard again yeah
please I'll see that's good that's good
now now say that one see that one I like
that one psych oh he's all that wouldn't
you look crazy that's cool though she's
made one more like I'm busy like I'll be
like this so I'm gonna mediate I'm gonna
say he's in a rush but he's into it see
I like that one
put moms I'm out hags arms are kind of
alright maybe try and plan out your nose
see I like that one yeah oh people with
flat noses laughing better people with
flat nose that's it call the kettle
black
no call them the cooking pan flat orange
chicken Bonnie I'm Korean at heart bro
yeah me and at septum let's go and do
one like just do we do the one or do one
like you're in a strip club and she's
the only girl in the world well no
that's like home school didn't work out
give me another look you look friendly
there see if I send that that's a
problem worse my stomach's poking out
here give me like this like I'm doing
business you idiot okay okay do it do it
like you you're making a big business
deal yeah you like you'd like a big deal
you idiot just do it like I'm a [ __ ]
actor garrison all right do it like do
it like you got a lot of like you got a
rush out of the office
well there you look stressed no one
wants hanging out sooner [ __ ] oh dude
what is this hello hello in a lot of
countries do a do one like like I wasn't
meant to set you up and I can't do this
I don't know one more one more
no I'm thinking you're not the person
that should be set me up with her - hey
hey hey I'll do that for you you know
ready just wink or was that a CTE flare
up okay one more all right
see I like that all right I'm gonna
Center right now and I'm gonna say no
that one's great it's not dude do not
send that dude is my family dude this
one's the best this one looks like
spring break boring to the listeners man
no that guy looks like uh-uh that's how
you look I try my best
yeah maybe it's just how I look try my
best Junior let's try one more I'm gonna
back up a little bit in the chair again
I wish I had a friend like like I can't
I wish I had a friend let me do this
like I can't agree with the deal like
I'm gonna send that and go okay hey this
goofball no I'm gonna say I'm gonna say
this goofball then but all it's a nice
girl or not 200 bucks and then put two
roses behind it like it's back page 200
bucks
Rose rose evil emotion eggplant Wow dude
I'll be I will be faces now makeup dude
make a sound then if you're gonna make a
face make a sound cuz the only thing I
know your face is a sound I love you
dude you know I don't know wow I tried
setting chin up man
exhausting
yeah exhausting elbows too pointy he's
like the [ __ ] reddit very picky
elbows too pointy
yeah to ears oh man she has too many
teeth
yeah oh I don't like her trachea Oh nose
is too flat for my liking oh she's too
old it's like dude she's 11 like oh I
don't like her almond shaped eyes two
eyeballs but Rosie breathing is she a
cool girl that girl or not yeah she's
really double smart girl very very
creative too because at first let me do
a painting of you as a giant rat with a
[ __ ] she piece of cheese get up
painting him for each one of us back
here being a we could do the rat
Brittany we're gonna hit you up you know
it'd be interesting and maybe each month
and we changed it out each month just
and I have a new artist every month do a
king to do a rat and a lost that's not a
bad idea
my good man maybe we could auction them
off for charity at the end of each month
Wow dude you're looking you're alike and
dude you just paint-by-number whoa I'll
wait with that that might not be the
girl actually that that's all huh that's
Brit no she seems like a wonderful girl
oh no this isn't her damn how thing can
we see other pictures of what this is
the this is her man she's great I'm not
saying this girl isn't great you want to
get another one if it's the same girl
I've been UFC ring-card girls but I'm a
Vanessa maybe Vanessa Hudgens no no her
name's is something like that it was
this are you talking about ariani
Celeste
no I just remembers a couple days you
step you're UFC game up yeah you're
annoying me how into the UFC you are
these days I'm annoying yeah you're just
trying to like get in with the UFC world
no you're trying to marry a ring-card
girl oh I can't be Dana White's no I
don't like Dana White you try to be his
little brother I would never be his
little brother dude which one his little
brother is a marshmallow dude if you had
a [ __ ] marshmallow that had was
filled with it evil center if you
cracked it open a net evil and the evil
pudding and people hey bro if you hit
that guy with an axe
evil pudding all over your shoes all
over you it's right there a second one
from the right sure
that's hurt well it's just different
lighting in different pit days I'll do
that for you again again everyone knows
the rules around Kingston if you want to
get to the trap you gotta go through the
honey yeah you gotta get through the
honey mall
oh it's like a charcuterie plate bro
yeah you know the cheese yeah if you
want to go through the cheese you got to
stop by that little dab of honey on the
place got to fill my cup up that sweet
cup and thirsty as you seem like a nice
girl I'm a smart girl most ring-card
girl that's the thing she was walking
around on my cause she's lost many girls
are lost you know but you were probably
seeing her walk you're like she's
walking different than the other she
might have there might be something here
that I'm looking to explore well she was
walking like she had at least at some
time in life carried a book bag on her
back you know like you smart hey I'll be
your million-dollar matchmaker you will
yeah you did we see Million Dollar Baby
no you haven't seen Miller oh is that
where Hilary Swank gets beat up
yeah yeah she gets defeated by the stool
you think she what if you did Hilary
Swank versus uh on Risa who'd oh that
guy that one the other night oh Henry
cejudo yeah
is it heavier Andre Andre I don't know
dude Hillary's famous it's pretty big
everything's tall so you'd have more
reach on dude you uh you talk about
gonna Dubai yeah I'm going you're gonna
go for sure well I have tickets well we
can figure out how to get your ticket I
can get you ticket that's easy
can you yes but you want to go to Dubai
well here's the thing I said to Bob Abu
Dhabi where it's Abu Dhabi first of all
Brennan thinks anywhere outside of
America's Dubai he's like I'm gonna do
buy England he told me the other day
he's like I'm going to Hawaii
I'm going like way in Dubai you just
want to go out there to support your boy
yeah I want to go see the fight it's
like this is his time you know this is
he he's you know this is his this is the
deal
it's the chance yeah yes so I mean I
think it would be fun to go you know I
just I don't want to get beat up they
can have a bunch of Slim's out there you
know Muslim yeah and I'll just disguise
yourself I thought about that coast one
of the girls in the ninja outfits oh
yeah have no idea yeah I could go to a
Bed Bath and Beyond and get out they
have a whole section for like middlee
like
Islamic female where do they yeah just
where that bears in the corner I have no
idea dude yeah it's like safe and they
just don't cheer too loud for Dustin
yeah they have no idea I'm like yeah
I'll just make a Santa in like chin I'll
be the chin cheer but yeah so I'm just
worried about I can't wear a disguise
first of all I got a big nose so me some
people can put on glasses and a big nose
and that's the disguise for me anytime I
put on glasses
it's just gives you away if you were
like oh who's that guy at the beach and
it's like oh that's just me man your
mullah to give you away they execute
people travel it's dude hold on they
execute people out there for having long
hair they do well I don't want to go
there I'm not going that bad where I'm
gonna get stoned in the street after you
know yeah that's not how many rounds do
they fight five oh wow 25 minutes bro do
you think they'll ever do tag-team no
let's start this show dude and I'm sorry
for saying also can we beep that we make
a note sure you didn't you don't want to
see the words you [ __ ] let's just
people want to hear it alright let's get
into it man sorry baby sorry dude but
all all hey do it again I wish I had a
friend like me do not wait head you know
what dude it just hit me I'm your genie
yeah I'm your big bumblebee genie really
yeah and you're Aladdin you got three
more wishes bro really yeah well let's
see if the first verse brands out that's
on her right you're looking for your
Jasmine yeah that thick ass genie trying
to make things happen for ya you ain't
never had a friend like me
alright we got you alright first gin
Sabu yo can you please do me a favor
shinza boo dude and roast so get your
little drama boo what's up my little
monkey with the thing yeah yeah crimes
your little snappers huh well first of
all that is a working actor and I'm in
I'm full blown lot wizard King there
okay oh there he goes
so give $100 to the lot lizard charity
condoms every every gas station put in a
truck stop every time I say lot lizards
all truck stops kid [ __ ] 5-hour
energy shots that's a free 5-hour energy
over there and uh at the Union 76
station off the ten in El Paso
yeah dude truck driver what of it man I
look like I should be on the blue comedy
tour some [ __ ] bro truck driver you look
like you're driving 200 dudes into your
butt bro
first of all you look like [ __ ]
Brendan back now you like silly Nelson
dude Dallas borrow you look like barf
Brooks
you look like Dallas returners club dude
you look like people getting a rebate
like good guy Brooks and dumb Brooks and
do any ton bro Brooks and Doug and
broken dunzo where are you I'm at a bar
are you really on set bro on set that's
apple juice on what set Bloods or Crips
dude you look like [ __ ] and I'm sorry I
shouldn't say I'm ass kind of means it's
not me man I think you look nice bro is
that uh is that a Patagonia button-up
what is that no it's a sleeveless
flannel that doesn't mean sleeveless
flannel brow that's Jack working actor
move on chin don't debate abuse yo do
you need red wine
I don't know 4:00 p.m. you need sushi
maybe a breakfast burrito whatever you
need you best be using post mates well
we'll say this I did order a once I got
a fat keto diet order to bread pudding
the other night at about 11:00 p.m. off
of a shady spot about 50 minutes away
from me 24/7 dude but it showed up in my
god dude Howard one slice of pizza the
other day no just one slice that's right
post mates your personal food delivery
grocery delivery whatever kind of
delivery you need all year round it's
called the lonely Italian when you get
that the lonely Italian used to be you'd
put on a show
Boyardee hat and pleasure yourself not
anymore now it's just a slice of
pepperoni yep 24 hours a day 365 days a
year
post mates will bring you whatever you
need
yep if you don't have an experience with
postmates Seng you got to experience it
because I was thinking what is this
somebody's gonna drive over food that I
want and that's exactly what they do you
feel like Tom Cruise you got your little
assistant just delivering whatever you
want
oh man you yeah you feel like any type
of cruise you want whatever yeah you
wanted somebody to cruise over some
snacks cruise over a [ __ ] you know a
bucket of water thing of uh you know
sandwiches 24/7 download the app for the
Android or Apple for free and you can
start getting it right now for a limited
time post mates has given you guys the
king of sting listeners $100 of free
delivery credit for your first seven
days that's right your delivery download
app use the code Kay ATS 2019 yep that's
it download the app is post mates and it
is the code Kay ATS two zero one nine
for $100 a free delivery credit for your
first seven days when you download the
post mates app so get the snacks get the
beautiful deals fill your face with
things that you want someone got to pay
for Till's haircut yo Theo when you're
selling online your orders out it can be
a beast man it's time-consuming it's
expensive there's so many to choose from
how do you know how do you know well
I'll tell you you gotta use shipstation
dot-com the fastest easiest most
affordable way to manage and ship your
orders yep I love ship station man if
I'm thinking of I have something and I
don't want to have it I want somebody
else to have it then I use ship station
if you have something you have to get
rid of send to somebody you know
anything I sent my dad a clock the other
day there you go no reason nope no
reason at all and with Father's Day
coming up hopefully you already ship
something out but if you haven't you can
be a week late and still send your
father something shipstation
works with all of the major carriers
including USPS FedEx UPS even Amazon
Fulfillment all of them and
you can compare the best shipping
solution for you and your customer
that's why ships station is the number
one choice of online sellers you'll ship
more in less time with the best rates
period and right now King the sting
Lister's can try ship station for free
for 60 days when you use the promo code
K ATS yep there's absolutely no risk you
can start your free trial right now
without even entering your credit card
info just visit ship station dot-com and
click on the microphone at the top of
the homepage and type in K 80s at
shipstation dot-com enter promo code k
80s yep you'll love it ship station make
ship happen someone's got to pay for
Brennan's coffee habit first segment of
the day is debate club man you got
acquitted you're gonna end up married to
some man trying to pull Tom Cruise well
you did the other movie where they say
you had a cowboy hat and a gun that's
how they bait you cartel right that's a
cartel member okay cartel it what you
will dude
then he'll you're just drinking beer by
yourself no sleeves whoo you're right so
I'm just saying in the next you know
they're like dude Brokeback Mountain -
yeah you're the horse yeah next thing I
know you're mr. hands Brokeback Mountain
- yeah did it in two years you're just a
puppet
you got some guy's hand up your butt
it's telling you what to do every wine
stain welcome to Hollywood all right
first one is Marino raw meat oh the
baked for you we're here at hundred-mile
in New York taste the country we got
country girls or rave girls oh I'm sure
we'll stiff with the twerk she was
twerking like you're the [ __ ]
jackhammer that back is tight oh yeah
she got that camera booty man let's
watch the butt shake again if you don't
mind now it's a little country girls or
rave girls it sounds like you're mad at
it man I'm not mad at that at all I'm
just saying I'm used to WorldStarHipHop
twerk videos they're a little looser in
there yeah well also those this girl
seemed more fit those girls are more
a lot of times on worldstar here you
really yeah why they fat dude fat fit I
got fat fit okay fine fit bodies broke
this she has that I will say that she
has that kind of like that strong female
rabbit type of flex yeah it's a it's a
quick rabbit hitter back then not too
loose like I don't know she's the best
salsa dancer right okay so no salsa but
it should drop that two-step hitter on
you though
oh that pico de thio two-step can we
watch again yeah
two-step I don't know the rest of the
words girls that's that
stiff old Home Depot rhythm brother yeah
that's that sexiest at-home Home Depot
whoo but here's the thing country girls
or rave girls country girls all day bro
all day girl they'll take carrier those
Southern Belles make you a pie make some
lemonade on the side oh nice just that
honey drip skin oh yeah that honey
drifts can read like a serial killer at
a bakery get you a Jenny Jenny was from
the south
who's Jenny Forrest Gump raging hormones
over her life but then when she decided
to be a southern belle who's never
taught the best well she had HIV yeah
sad HIV dude I think I know she had AIDS
it doesn't say that she died at the end
she died she died Jenny died dude
remember oh yeah that's part of the
movie yeah no [ __ ] I don't watch the end
of that movie I usually stop at about an
hour and 55 minutes a three hour movie
so you stop it right when he discovers
an Apple huh yeah I stop it when the
party's going strong I feel you you know
I'm not there at the end when he's got
the kid and the kid has a handicaps and
everything
dude also rave girls I'm not trying to
be up all goddamn night on cocaine
ecstasy yes the [ __ ] Diplo with seven
other dudes by now but I thought I pop
on I thought it sweating yeah I like
girls when the weekends over they go
back to work or school yeah rave girls
are a lot of times they here's the thing
they don't also take care of themselves
they don't eat they got all these
necklaces on and they all they're
dressed up like a lot of Rainbow Brite
addicts there you got a [ __ ] IV drip
of Monster energy drink right into the
vanes and [ __ ] yeah and they'll have
yeah a lot of these rave girls - they're
doing unique stuff like you'll see them
you know dipping their arm these pawns
Eastham pawns and new I you know MDMA
and stuff like that and for Japan they
call it when you're tripping through
your vagina the dripping the chip in
pagina the other thing is is they kept
you can never just chill yeah it always
has to be like crazy color yeah how
about a white or black [ __ ] it's always
like a giant neon a neon green a hot
pink hot purple yeah like somebody beat
ya it's always like yeah it always feels
like they all look like mascots of the
[ __ ] Toronto Raptors yeah I look
weird all the time just be normal you
get the shoes of the huge platforms on
them like this big yeah they look like
one of their parents was a highlighter
that's what they look like a lot of
times it looks like both their parents
were [ __ ] and were two highlighters
you see him in the you see him usually
in the lobby in Las Vegas and they're
all like they're covered in there
they're like usually have like a bunch
of like rabbit ears on and they're
dressed like half of a koala and uh and
then they're also been crying but
they're sweating and they're dehydrated
all sweating to hydrate it didn't have a
slight layer of parking-lot dust on them
yeah yeah parking lot fairies is what I
call fairies now with that said very
sexy women okay now the country girls
you get them out there they got the
boots on you know they're a little bit
more the songs are a little bit more
like camaraderie a little bit more
family-oriented
you know you might um you know you might
see at it but you might not yeah they
might make you wait before you get
married you know I'm saying yeah the
ravers you'll see two girls out there
chewing on each other's tongues until
they literally have eaten each other's
faces off and you're like oh this is a
party yeah ravers be doing so many drugs
he might just eat your dick off oh yeah
I don't want that man and they'll do
that too in the morning oh they think
the world just runs 24 yeah no idea they
think everything's open 24 hours a day
yeah and the country girls shut it down
because they got to feed their kids in
the morning you got a cooking [ __ ] yeah
[ __ ] country girls all day
gang brah ohm 72% of the audience agrees
with you
I feel like rave girls is going out of
style now that's the thing rave girls is
going out of sight if you're still being
her if girl then I respect it you're a
late bloomer
I am too dude I still do a lot of things
that other people gave up on years ago
but um I stopped hogs yeah what's up but
if you're The Rave things over the rape
thing is go home if you're still raving
you're a drug addict basically youyou
just mean drug addict and I saw you mean
hanging out with your friends doing
drugs late into the night playing music
doesn't work man oh man okay well climb
out of that [ __ ] and put on some Jason
Aldean let's go chin all right this is
an interesting debate from Kennedy Space
what's up Brandon what's up the oh Lisa
been watching you all day and I have a
debate club question for you
so as a transgender woman I was
wondering your thoughts on whether or
not someone like me has to disclose that
information
on a first date with a guy I would love
to hear your thoughts gang game buzz
buzz oh that's a good question you want
to jump in first you want me to I think
someone should disclose their sexuality
on a first date but I I think you you
think wait to the first date because the
the and it's it's not my doing but
Society
especially with dudes just when a lot of
transgender people get beat up is
because dude might flip the [ __ ] out if
he doesn't know ahead of time
oh well I've sent like a message to that
I thought was a woman before and said
hey how are you or something and on
social media and then 200 messages is in
it's like oh this is a there's a young
fella
and you can tell because they're using
our well here's an end you just go back
through their photos and it's a
beautiful woman you know and it's a
beautiful human and then you keep going
back and then like four years back
they're like on the high you know boys
high school basketball team you're like
oh this is a bizarre like rather taking
pictures of Jeff yeah like who's yeah
why this I thought your name was jasmine
write it so then yeah so so I think some
disclosure I
you shouldn't honey dick too though man
like that's not being honest here you
don't want to be honest now beyond I'll
be honest okay here we go I was like a
young beautiful lady I thought ass you
know I'm saying skinny waist makes you
know combo conversation I get a video
jacking off someone's jackknifed went Oh
was that your brother jacking off but no
it's me lit okay we got dick not my
thing
but good for you you know I'm saying wow
that's the way to be up front is what
I'm saying that's why I'm trying to tell
you deal right well why would you ask if
somebody send you a video of say you're
hitting on a girl yeah they sing you a
video of somebody Kirk it off why would
your question be your brother cuz I
thought it was a girl and I thought
that's weird but even if it is their
brother you don't reply like what do you
hey is that your brother like what is
that well then my detective side comes
out and like what's going on how much
weight you should watch the first four
dude I know but give me nobody leaves
you can count to 48 I'll say this a
respective site encyclopedia big brown
he's the detective that never finds out
[ __ ] never find any you never crack the
case whose gets stuck in traffic and a
fine
purple limousine I'll tell you this I
for one license Gentiles take I like to
transit I thought feels transgender for
the longest just turns out he's just
confused I'm just confused he's actually
a dude he's just two roads diverged in a
wood you know what can I say man I'll
say this man uh that first of all you
seem like a beautiful young fella you
seem like a beautiful young woman woman
and here's it now here's the thing from
a straight male perspective here's the
thing that makes it tough sometimes with
transgender is a it's a new it's not a
new thing that's going on but it's a new
thing that is out in the open and so for
straight men are for me sometimes I
can't speak for remember for me it's
just hard to know what's protocol and a
lot of times the gay community or trans
LG
BQ a.m. or whatever already F yeah W and
quit adding letters let's be realistic
just get one name yeah us so a lot of
times they will immediately chastise you
if you don't get the right term or
something like that there's no learning
curve so I think the best way to be is
just upfront just say at a certain point
like if you feel like you are tricking
another person yeah and you know when
you are
yeah then say hey look I just want you
to be are you aware of this now if
they're rude to you after that or
they're mean to you you don't vote with
them anyway yeah [ __ ] them call them out
blast them out yes show me a video you
bentham 500 pounds yeah
but if they're uh but then also it could
just be a learning experience you could
always meet up with somebody and and get
their vibes some guys that might be
afraid to try and meet up with the
transgender person they you know they
might be trying to reach out to you and
just be be a little bit scared yeah they
might know what's up from the jump and
they might want to may know the magic
trick already yeah I have some friends a
lot of times and they you know low-key
they like having uh they like doing sex
with transgender people that they meet
on the Internet
there's your friend named Eddie Murphy
nope his name's our friend named Thomas
Downey jr. no but it's also like as your
friend's name Bryan Callen so should
there be full disclosure was that her
question chance yeah she should you'd
let them know I the way I think she
should let him know just from a safety
aspect well here's the thing if I showed
up in a disguise right and I'm not
saying the transgender is a disguise
people are used to a certain way if I
show up at a rodeo dressed up like I'm
about to ride the bull and then I get
out on there and I'm a painter
people can bike what the [ __ ] dude you
know you can't just you know be drop you
know dripping Sherwin Williams on this
uh on this beautiful animal this animal
we're expecting you to be a bull rider
I'm gonna get pissed so at a certain
point if you if you are a do if you if
you are such a beautiful transgender
woman that it's that it's tough to tell
that it's so tough to tell you might
want to just drop a few hints throw an
eggplant at the end of an emoji you know
or drop a couple no reason yes I think
dropping some hints you throw the
cucumbers
yeah nobody's required to do anything
but I think you just need to from a
safety standpoint you gotta say what's
up yeah for yourself in for everyone
just if you know if you're tricking
somebody you know if somebody feels
elusive I know it in a straight on
straight thing if I'm to David Blaine
knows it yeah
even David Blaine knows if he's tricking
somebody so I think just play it by ear
there's no protocol but don't also
chastise somebody if they don't know
that you're transgender cuz there's no
were strict and pulling a dick out well
but also after the nice young date
don't make somebody feel bad if they
didn't know there's that there's two
things that go on it's like people make
you know people are always accused of
making gay people feel unwelcome and
this and that but at the same time you
can't make somebody feel unwell you
can't make somebody feel wrong if they
didn't know if they got surprised by a
baby if they got their face Jesus Christ
Oh God and edit it out no we don't need
to edit I like where you're going with
it but you know if they give you a road
eat myself four times 17 times sorry who
has CT here brah
who has CT oh we should have a CTE off
oh we should you definitely win no I've
never been punched in the face ever yes
I have dude I got attacked by a couple
of [ __ ] Dobermans still on a birthday
and when I was even younger a painter
next-door sicked his dog on me that
works what else you got chin all right
last one
jhope amante you guys might recognize
this guy or know of him Gang Gang
buzz-buzz drip drip it was just the
episode where all the above yo I got a
debate club for you Horace
this is Joey I'm your candle maker guy
out here and Colorado hold her down man
and that is my question when it comes
time to make the vibes you do I do you
like candles or do you burn a little
incense what do you like man keep up the
good work guys
I would like incense better if it if
they had instance that smelled like
certain restaurants like I would love
you throw on a [ __ ] McDonald's you
know on a PF Changs oh yeah right oh
there's no PF Changs them titties are a
pop n throw on a stinky uber drivers car
to get at throwing a nice young Thai
restaurant incense you know I'm saying
incense that because I really don't do a
little CT and forget where you're at
call the cops forget what you're at and
then also at the end of so like Bill
Cosby a little but dude that'd be great
good King inside Wilms certain
situations yeah why don't we met smells
like a pawn shop just old watches in
[ __ ] medallion yeah whole watches and
people getting [ __ ] over for their
family heirlooms yeah why don't we yeah
you could do like a pirate ship smells
old but a little bit of salt a little
bit of seasoning dude that's a great
idea
dammit ID at all wonder how we find that
I didn't do that I still want to get
that semen lava lamp when you're in
college everybody you're often in that
thing I know you make one giant love
where the whole frat bust in the same
body come see our bust oh yeah
our bus bulb come see it bulbs how is
that not a thing bus bomb call your
[ __ ] brother do if he quit doing
bicep curls and [ __ ] do some [ __ ] and
actually make some money instead of just
Church stealing [ __ ] off his brother
like Dane Cook's brother you know Jay
Shaw is the next [ __ ] Larry cook does
his brothers named Larry get dressed
Larry come on taint those names Larry of
course he stole your [ __ ] Larry country
doing curls on your dime
okay no incense bro yeah I want that
Johnny Depp [ __ ] incense I want to
burn that instant smells like [ __ ]
bad meat I want to burn burn that nick
nolte incense it smells like dinosaur
bone and [ __ ] and like your kid hates
you
yeah I'll burn that [ __ ] [ __ ] is every
extremely famous celebrity have a son
that is a complete [ __ ]
because he's dad so [ __ ] famous I
need that isn't that crazy though the
that everything is just it's such a
teeter totter man everything has that
other
side you don't get to famous otherwise
your kid gets really weird like look at
Will Smith's kid yeah look at Will Smith
genders on e-bumper maybe we don't know
yeah rapper writer I love how every
month is a different thing it is put it
I don't have [ __ ] smoothie city it's
like okay pick a lane bro
yeah it doesn't end though it's Nick
Nolte's child Tom Hanks's child you know
Chaz Bono well this is that level the
other side of it that's the thing
everything is even in the world man it's
like everything is easy but here's a
little problem though all the being
appeared all the people you're talking
about
they were never around for the kids the
kids are there to figure out with the
nanny and the kids growing up weird
yeah only time the dad brings you around
is that [ __ ] red carpet this is life
this weird fishbowl yeah I love me so
much I'll take you to this thing with me
now I love you so much let me fight you
to Dubai so you can hear Polar Express
yeah for the premiere of pirates the
Carribean 19 where your dad puts [ __ ]
mascara on in a bandana
I now know and 17 [ __ ] wristbands
imagine weird dude you're growing weird
it's the weirdest kids out here man
this [ __ ] place bro Oh what else were
we talking about oh yeah but hold on
shout out to my boy out there would hang
over candles and that's my boy Joey
Piedmont over there hanging over
Colorado's finest bro yep a good guy he
sent us in some beautiful candles and
Joey I like the wide the wine bottle
ones because there's more easy to get
that wick with that lighter cuz I've
cooked out both of my thumbs look like
I'm trying to burn cook crack rocks on
my knuckles alright well ninety sorry 89
percent of fans also prefer candles and
going back to the transgender disclosing
92% people say yes please do that now
it's everyone's favorite time it's a
commercial from King in the state yo do
yes step your game up bro with India
chinos the world's most exciting
made-to-measure menswear company out
there yeah Indo Chino man I got a suit
from them and it I'll say this man
you're a red carpet-ready
dude i was ray corporate all i dinna
needed to order a red carpet I'm like
damn now I gotta buy a couple hundred
cubic yards of red carpet next thing you
know I'm in my yard by myself paint the
grass red so guess what man Hinda Chino
makes suits and shirts to your exact
measurements for
the best look you can get whatever
you're looking to do maybe you want to
get married they got tons of options for
that wedding oh when you get married you
want to get murdered whatever you want
to do funeral you got a buddy who passed
away get them that endo Chino hit or
send them to heaven happy yeah make sure
you look good no matter what you're
doing this how it works a visit a
stylist at their showroom they've over
40 showrooms in North America and have
them take your measurements personally
or you can measure at home and you can
go online shop online at in to chino
dot-com choose your fabric choose your
design submit your measurements with
your choices relaxed where your shoot
gets professionally done like your back
in the day Italian suit looking like a
diamond I'm it is a meatball in my
cumberbund look at the fresh this week
it's Italian brother you can open up the
lapel and hear somebody getting drop a
meat dibala Carla's Anya this week the
King sing listeners get any premium Indo
Chino suit for just three hundred fifty
nine dollars at Indo Chino calm when you
enter promo code que 80s at checkout
that's 50% off the regular price
made-to-measure look like a die look
like a dino show up like a nickel endo
Chino has got the quality free shipping
that's in the Chino dot-com promo code
que 80s for any premium suit for just
359 free shipping once you go custom you
never go back support the podcast
yo deal you've heard about neighborhood
watch groups write neighborhoods looking
out for each other my neighbor he always
knows what's up he always knows what's
yes cuz your neighbors a peeping tom
dude is he or does he just use a ring oh
yeah man with ring you know what's going
on on your front porch you know what's
going on across the street you have a
really good idea with the neighbors app
from ring you receive real-time crime
and safety alerts from your neighbors it
helps you stay informed about what's
going on in your neighborhood do you
have a neighborhood well
know what's going on you got a man it's
so easy all you do is you open the ring
app and go to the neighbor's feed browse
through the feed of alerts reported by
your neighbors this is what I do I just
moved in a new crib and I'm already part
of my neighborhood watch
what's up and I'm watching all over yeah
get it sit at lunch and have a snack and
see who's it running through their
neighborhood steal and are doing
fireworks or whatever you know you can
know the best part is listen man
neighborhoods are beginning a lot safer
neighborhood watch is powered by people
yep neighbors people they go
hand-in-hand like peanut butter and
jelly so if you want to help make sure
your neighborhood is safe download the
free neighbors app today go to ring.com
/ke 80s to download from Apple iPhone
Android whatever you want
that's ring.com slash kate 80s yep you
can you can find out if you if somebody
lost a pet if somebody lost to item if
somebody's Nate you know little neighbor
son is sneaking over trying to holler at
your daughter you know what's going on
Jim threw the ring through the neighbors
feed get it get get it get it make your
neighborhood safer today with the
neighbors app by ring trying to keep the
lights on you guys ready for a front my
aunt yeah alright first aunt she likes
cream barbecue wears bikinis around the
house her name is aunt Selena
what's some facts on the scent she oh
she likes Korean barbecue obviously
wears bikini and what are some facts
let's go to chin for the facts tea
there's a lady's Korean is she Korean no
no so she was like Elena that's pretty
much it so she likes Korean barbecue
words bikinis around the house and this
was submitted by Stephen uh Lee and
Stephen he might be she's inked up to
wearing bikini around the household
string well she has a tattoo of the the
kid from The Addams Family on her hip
keep zoom in on that guy yeah
fester Addams whatever that is and but
very beautiful of the latticework behind
me you can see water back behind her if
you notice that on the water back um you
should in the Midwest they do have a
flooding problem right now so maybe
that's what's going on here was she's in
bikini Selena in the Midwest first of
all hopefully that's not her the person
who runs her fan club that little boy
with her because that person will kill
her have you seen Selena oh right the
manager shot her for no reason at all
yeah do you the worst Mexican I've ever
met right
first of all shout out to all of our
Mexican friends welcome to America and
uh and yeah Selena very sad very very
sad
first of all a lot of great Latino
singers died
Selena Ricci valance a bomba Ricky
Martin Ricky Martin yeah senior think
mr. t mr. t very sad man but yes Selena
got them T us you know get them let's
check home Tomales yeah yeah okay so
pick up the guy at the house Spanish bro
you're the worst person ever man I'm not
Spanish bro yeah you are no dude I'm
wider than you do you know Mexican you
harken bro 80%
yeah maybe dude I get a lot of weird
looks you know yeah brother some weird
looks those are Mexican friends well
those are probably gangbangers papa no
when I pull into Home Depot everyone's
like hey I'm like alright do you don't
need any work but they just like there's
our mascot dolls you doing at home you
lady
dude you made a halt seriously bro next
life bro I'm telling you I'm coming
Feliz Navidad and being Mexican next
time boy gonna be Mexican Santa Klaus
yeah coming down the chimney Oh Papa
Papa Papa stole us hey
well you are a definite oh uh uh oh now
we're stopping you at the border dude
you're you're done shut up - beautiful
aunt Selena thank you for taking us here
you got a wish I don't like that my aunt
looks like [ __ ] you - look like dragons
what else yet
next up is uncle mark and I got some
stats on this guy mark anyone need
trimming I'm from your crazy ass is this
son is he a serial killer Rose this from
Ebaum's world
I feel like looks like every pitcher off
that website e bombs world and he might
be a homosexual as well or homosexual
[Music]
yeah down all right 62 years old still
pulls girls off on MySpace he's a
retired truck driver now owns a
landscaping / gigolo business huh yeah
and then I'll just stop it there
yeah it's too jokey for me um to art me
- we want serious [ __ ] inquiries only
whoever did Nick or chind you picked
this Nick did so we're gonna slap creepy
Nick when we get done with this this is
yeah I mean the guy six years old I love
that he looks respectable he's an
outdoorsman that part I get
he's a chainsaw owner which I respect
that a man that owns a saw not mad at
his tits yeah it was like a guy who has
tits isn't afraid to show it
yeah agreed but the guy have the sick
you know the still pulls girls off
myspace at that point is just like what
are we doing here you know it's not
realistic so thank you for submitting
them but no thank you for submitting
them ma'am all right relationship advice
[Music]
are we don't [ __ ] touch my hands warm
bro it's been on my nuts for about ten
minutes
all right lets me do that I smelled like
Top Ramen
what do we got first ones from Jen rocks
of Texas oh yeah hey guys kinking buzz
buzz
Jennifer from Texas here meeting some
relationship advice I am single and in
my 30s
and I find that I'm having so much
problems in the dating world because I
am a homebody I am so completely
introverted I like to stay home and read
and watch movies and work out I don't
know how to put myself out there because
I don't really thrive in social
situations and so what should I do
I've tried the online dating no one
blows my mind enough to wanna like leave
my little cave and I just need your help
but I gotta go get my throws coming on
King King buzz-buzz and I begin our own
game of thrones' so yesterday but carry
on but it's like figure it out I agree I
just you're on a small island yeah just
go over just go over one [ __ ] death
date Popeye how about sending a bird to
somebody it's like hey think your horse
yeah look I got the road let's split a
loaf of syphilis and [ __ ] chat right
you know start having babies create your
own [ __ ] Kingdom it's easy get his
dragon shut your [ __ ] mouth
so with this chick though so she doesn't
do well in social environments good
thing is with this day and age with
Instagram tinder grinder bumblebee
bumper JDate farmers only you don't have
to and she's like I know I've tried all
the dating sites I get that listen if
you're gonna fish you want to catch that
Marlin you gotta catch some [ __ ]
toads before you catch that Marlin you
catch my drift the big old Marlin is out
there you just gotta keep fishing girl
keep on fishing and hopefully you don't
catch a catfish you know I'm saying it's
me fishing I fish for I fish for a deal
yeah what's up bro do you see huntin
that's all sex that's all dating is
deep-sea hunting but I think you're
trying to do too much at once by making
it all happen but sitting on the apps
and just being judgemental at a certain
point it just doesn't help us I used to
do it and then next thing you know I'd
sit there at night but like yeah but as
told a thousand people no time to
masturbate and go to sleep and that was
my life wouldn't let us raft by yourself
Oh jerking off into an empty [ __ ]
Carl's jr. box say that double western
urinating in a cup because I've
masturbated so many times I don't have
enough energy to get to the bathroom
been there bro so it's just a matter of
the future you want to have right now
it's looking pretty sad well yeah it was
jacking off in a [ __ ] Orange Julius
talking about I didn't say that what
else we got a good luck girl
we got Hannah from forints Kentucky hey
guys my name is Hannah and I have a
relationship question my husband is a
very well-endowed which I love fix it
it does take me a couple of days to
Central recover afterward most of our
marriage his schedule is only allowed
for maybe twice a week and his schedule
just changed and now it is everyday I
just don't know what to do about it
because I'm not really into saying no
but I also don't want to be a
wheelchair-bound for the rest of my life
so whatever you guys think let me know
okay gang you better get them feet mouth
ready well he's just Christ don't you
think about anything but sex you idiot
her questions about sex yeah but you
could hear a child in the background and
you're saying that's on the mouth ready
well that's on her bro yeah it's on her
but it's also on trying to help her dude
but can you imagine the listeners of
this episode of this podcast they hear a
child's voice it and then you come
dubbing in over it better get your mouth
ready mouth and feet ready dude I'm
trying to solve a problem for this young
lady with dope here and her man got that
[ __ ] panther tail between his legs
solving problem it was once a week right
and there's twice a week you say twice
without every every day so it's a real
problem yeah I heard her frickin problem
I'm trying to figure it out dude are you
hey hey why don't we have the kid Barca
you know have the kid to his times
tables in the background and Brennan can
you know show pictures of uterus or
whatever makes him feel happy hey man
I'm sorry freaking her problem
I don't need the kid in the background
you just gotta get creative man you
don't you don't have to be so every day
man
what do you what do you think should do
Dale well here's the thing you knew when
you married the guy what was going on
between his legs it's not like he's
surprising you suddenly at 50 years old
he gots a couple extra you know cubic
inches of wiener
so the pterodactyl yeah if he's all of a
sudden you know if he's pulling big root
all of a sudden you know you can't you
know claim it was a radish when you knew
it was a patate you know what I'm saying
so I think but you can also set
boundaries you guys have children you
know and you can't just be doing sex all
day if they got children around so I
would say look honey two times a week
it'll keep the excitement going and a
buildup you know I'm saying yeah just
because obviously your husband lost his
job which he didn't want to say doesn't
mean you guys should be doing sex all
day in fact during the Great Depression
people weren't having that much sex
because they didn't want to have extra
children because they couldn't feed them
so now you're depressed yeah so I don't
think you need to be just having sex do
something else get a puzzle get a table
outdoors so you have to do stuff
outdoors in public like you know eat
outdoors don't need inside where people
could have sex after maybe let them go
to shady massage places yeah get them a
masseuse
you know get him a massage shop one of
our Chin's buddies you recommend any
places chin I don't remember off the top
of my head and I think here's one called
that off the top of my head see if you
just google search that anywhere in
Tampa Florida I'm sure you'll find a
spot but look I think just lovingly tell
him look we already have some offspring
you're off of work so I just think it's
time for us to you know shut down the
womb and get that womb filler they have
a thing you can get on the internet
we're just kind of it's like a detour
thing for your vagina you know it kind
of just like just like as a stopper like
a blocker every day's ridiculous ship
especially if he has a pterodactyl oh
yeah if he's showing up with a damn
safety cone yeah you got a
yeah what else we got a good luck girl
all right it's that time again oh it
ready bed Brenna's menstrual cycle
what better dead wet better dead oh this
is original
first let's our Shannon from Ohio hey
I'm Shannon and I'm sending in this
video because I really like the portion
of the wet bed or dead last week's
podcast is really funny I love the
Golden Girls but I think I can top the
options this week so they're all three
of them are amazingly gorgeous and your
options are Bryan Callen Chris D'Elia
and Joe Rogan I know how will you ever
choose anyway can't wait to see who you
choose and feel hopefully I'll be seeing
you in October at one of your Shevlin
can't wait for that too alright thanks
guys have a good one I think you were
saying my name first also in the
beginning oh man s hand and was her name
yes s Shannon that's Hannon yes uh this
one's pretty easy because you want to
marry Rogan he's so rich
well no you're into so you're obviously
giving away a lot about yourself so
you're taking care of if you're a young
lady so you wanna you want to marry ro
you don't think uh Chris D'Elia or Bryan
Callen can take care of someone not
financially like Rogan can what have you
seen Chris D'Elia bro I've seen him I've
seen him uh dude the other day he had a
family in the back of his G Wagon this a
random family he was taking care of bone
he was taking care of they had oh he had
a baby with him like an actual infant it
had a bottle in the bottle was two
thousand dollars cash no milk and the
kid was socket on that socket he does
just have a cold
oh yeah he does have his own cold oh
there's a picture on the internet - uh
somebody committed a crime and a baby in
a baby's hurt he reposted yeah well I
robbed a bank in a baby shirt they're
like is it posted I'm not joking there's
a crime somebody committed says anybody
has anybody seen this fella anywhere in
this area call this police number with
you
two guys stealing something a baby huh
it's hilarious but s Hana I would say
there s Hannon sorry I would say ah
dammit
that power just went out of here chin
fired our and we had to fire Derek - I
would Derek fired himself let's be
honest what's going on quit there didn't
you work with a family reunion yeah um
God who would you kill out of them you
have to go all three do your three
please
ah Maron Rogen bed Chris D'Elia is a
cult I'm have to kill Bryan Callen bro
you're already blowing Krystal here you
might as well I can't just go all the
way with Jesus dude if I see you on
Instagram like one more way to go buddy
that's what you wrote the other day on a
picture of him I was like Rogan like use
your therapist may like haven't heard
from them have you in like yeah man it'd
be quit asking well how how oft you
should feed your hamsters maybe that's
why is that getting back to you bro
they're beautiful you start charging by
the hour for advice dude whatever you've
already late you've already made your
bed dude I'm gonna say this man I
wouldn't marry Bryan Callen because I
would never leave my friend behind and
and he's a good guy and I know that he
also has trouble in relationships and so
do I so we could at least be there for
each other I mean cheat on each other
another way to put it
so then after him yeah dude
well first of all I think yeah I would
have to cry don't have to kill Chris
D'Elia because he is the he's my mortal
enemy and a lot of people know that you
know I'll be at shows and somebody will
[ __ ] you know and then and then
thousands of other people will cheer so
it's uh you know he has a cult and
they're all about sucking and [ __ ]
and uh and you know I'm sort of the
other end of the the teeter-totter and
so you know I'm about trying not to jerk
off and and just doing our best
God Jesus look at him different you
might as well open up a YMCA Jesus crowd
loved that yeah I know you would oh I'd
give anything to have a [ __ ] swim
team oh we can do it we make this happen
for you bro and then uh and then our
organ oh I'd probably know you don't
kill the other one kill no kill Chris
Thalia I said okay so then you know and
I said yeah I'd have to make love to Joe
Rogan or be or be made love to by him
yeah yeah you definitely bottom bro oh I
don't think I'm going top on your road
no please don't like that he's power
[ __ ] oh I can't I mean look I would
also take some sedatives or I would
disconnect my the nervous system from my
body for the waist down so I couldn't
feel it yeah you didn't feel like that
young lady was for relationship advice
with her husband with the pterodactyl oh
yeah just two times a week Joe please I
think that would be it for me so our
only difference was I would marry Joe
you would kill Joe yeah they're all duds
see with bright yeah they're all
different all right
our only difference was all of them all
of them if you want an all-too more
different if you want no pretty nice
thought processes and how they differ
it's all of them do that one all right
next one up is I think it's gyasi yeah
see from Sacramento California your
thing the Heat's on in here game game
buzz buzz sting sting gay gay Tyler from
Michigan got wet bed or dead for you and
it's the Jennifers Jennifer Aniston
Jennifer Lawrence and Jennifer Lopez JLo
and I got that hitter right now a
surgery but yellow Theo I'm still gonna
come see you in Detroit October gang
gang baby let's go gang gang brother and
drop me an email through my website man
and we'll get you make sure that we get
to meet up with you and say hello man I
want to write my name on that leg he got
to you guys at home and just listen you
can't see that man have a arm special
like a mummy leg or yeah what is surgery
yeah looks like any surgery a cast sorry
he never cast on did he yeah he was a
house with like a middle-earth
you guys are either way I've Nick
wheelman yourself the guy's bedridden
yeah see those like a piece of metal
there too yeah the guys know surgery
yeah they don't put those in cast great
sign is cast it was tyler say his name
his name's gyasi shut up the times gyasi
wet better dead Jennifer's working with
animals here gyasi thank you for
emailing Tyler well then why did you
write it as Geoff's is bad in high your
bro well then how do you misspell Tyler
as gyasi you ask the person that write
that I wrote that and who is it I don't
know guess I'm not gonna name names he's
somewhat creepy Nick again okay it's not
creeping it gets premature Nick no it's
creepy Nick on this end he was born
three weeks early I'm creepy the staff
is just you calling them crazies guys
Chin's afraid to say his name his name
Nick father and chin didn't want to say
it last when Chan was forced into the
driver no right even though black Derek
is the one who didn't show up to work
take your anger out on black Derek dude
we don't have our you know why the show
is a little weird today one of our
culture corner cuz cat got a rack driver
and then Derek's at a family reunion oh
so we have the most horse of course
they're missing ain't that a [ __ ] it's
a dicot I saw this coming
yep people want to say well what are
these you know white guy because the
reason why white guys are because
they're at work okay
Asian people are getting in accidents
constantly black people are constantly
at the family reunion but we still take
the risk in Hiram don't we and that date
show they show they throw shade at us oh
dude I just got a form yesterday a yeah
hurt on the job form from Derrick so
well shut out the cat hopefully she's
okay yeah shut out the cat hope she's
okay I'm assuming she's probably driving
a Honda do you know Ken it was a Honda
Accord he does Drive honey just drive a
Honda Accord yes I said what happened
she said just life yes just life just
drive it yep ran into a pole Oh see the
pole
all right he's okay though and our
thoughts and prayers are with hat today
what better dead
you're not large Jennifer Lopez or
Jennifer Aniston the Jennifer's okay man
first of all I'm Erin Jennifer Lopez cuz
she is ah yeah she's also fifty yeah
she's fifty online that means sixty in
France in sixty in Afghanistan in France
is like a [ __ ] problem bro
jennifer aniston dead I would go
Jennifer
he's the owner Jennifer Lawrence yeah I
wouldn't even talk to get it for
Lawrence suit you get some my [ __ ]
nerves okay so I'd rather this jerk-off
outside and then who's the other one
Jennifer Lopez Jennifer Lopez I like JLo
dude me - I just wanna maybe JLo kill
the other two but Ben Affleck's ex-wife
that would be my Jennifer oh yeah oh you
like the Jennifer Jennifer Dean James
Dean or Jimmy Dean's daughter the
sausage king Oh
[Music]
what else yeah this is King Eater sting
it first up is Tyler from New York oh no
this is Tyler the other [ __ ] Aussie
Aussie Aussie man there we go Brennan
Gang Gang buzz buzz baby a huge fan of
show man and a quick question for you
guys
chest hair do you like it or do you not
like it should you keep it or should you
shave it I'm gonna put a Rico in a few
weeks with my boys on vacation and I had
quite a bit man so I shaved it all off
not sure if it was the right move or not
but you know it is what it is now who's
looking to see you guys it's feedback
can't sting it debate club I'll let you
guys do your thing man love you guys
please love you man you guys got a cool
vibe here's my thing if you're super
hairy that's God's work just live with
the hair man like if you're Armenian
there's some my dad has super hairy
forearms you just gotta let it grow man
oh that's God's painting that's what
he's doing he's painting all over your
chest all over your back maybe on your
face just leave it yeah gonna be weird
don't be weird dude so what are you
telling him I'm telling you should have
left it cuz when he left his shirt up
just doesn't like match
can you go back to the shirt uplift I'm
not gonna look but have Brennan look at
the belly button please please
acknowledge the deep crater of that
belly button scroll down a little chin
right there it's the deepest belly but
you've ever seen your life but it's very
deep huh mmm man smooth like a seal yeah
but it seemed like he still really
misses his mother I mean that is a deep
bellybutton deep connection this jeepers
downtown baby um can you take it off of
him with his shirt up like that kid can
I what do you want you to take it down
now to keep the man's chest up for us
for 20 seconds that's what he wants
though man also a lot of hairy dudes I
think girls dig I'm not a hairy dude so
I'm not not at all I don't know where
it's coming from but you know you look
at all the Beast dudes out there you
know Hugh Jackman Burt Reynolds EO
training if you look at him on Instagram
who's Brennan he's hairless too though
the hairless chimp it's you that's
what's a hairless chimp let be me if I
took every steroid in the book well look
at this bucko
here's what I'll say to you and we have
to get through this damn episode okay
Nick gets through the episodes a little
quicker I'll say that that this guy I
like it it's a good question I think it
also depends on your age if you're under
30 you can still do the chest shaved
thing if you're over 30 I think you got
to let the hair grow out you can't uh
you know unless you get waxed getting
wax is one thing but you can't like I
used to do like the IH dude like a
number two on my chest and show off but
it's like I look like I had a big front
side burn with nipples on the edges
right got a five o'clock shadow in your
teeth so I think that's where you just
have to be be cautious but also don't be
weird about it once you get it whatever
decision you make rock with it the back
though is the thing that if it gets to
here you got to get it waxed dude you
know I'm going back to no no bro
shoulders yeah the shoulders is very
scary if you have hairy shoulders you
are to any girl you are an uncle or yeah
so you just got to get it waxed off I
think if you're gonna be at the pool if
you're at work all day in a suit if
here in your shoulders you know you are
there's no doubt it's hard to [ __ ]
you got have mints in your pocket and
uncle with mint in your pocket if here
on your [ __ ] shoulders
dude if you put your and also like you
said about your father with the wrist
hair or whatever before on is very
alarming also going down and a woman
that has a lot of hair on her thighs
it's very dangerous and very unique but
I would get it I would get it on
whatever choice you make rock with it
but over 30 I think you have to let it
go gods were under 30 I think you you
it's okay to shave it if you're on an
MTV Spring Break shave it yeah if you're
going it depends on where you're going
to like I think if you're getting cool
hairless yeah Cancun hairless of the
Poconos hair here gotta have it yeah
well I would ask Brendon where the
Poconos are but I already know that he
doesn't know [ __ ] also doesn't know I
certainly knew you didn't know dude
sorry so [ __ ] asian up or asian out
alright okay next up Nick knows where
they are
let's go let's ask him alright next one
up is Anthony and Humberto Brendan and
Theo
Anthony me Umberto here and grenades
King Gator stinging lunch grenade that's
the best video I've ever seen on this
show dude oh dude I salute you guys
broke two-handed salute - oh my god Wow
high salute baby dude don't [ __ ]
salute me bro
don't [ __ ] salute cannot [ __ ] do
it hell I [ __ ] dude since I was a kid
I was throwing fake hand grenades dude
we that's the first time I've ever seen
a real one I could be honest I saw a
real one one time they had a somebody
had this Livestock Show in our town and
somebody flipped the [ __ ] out and threw
one Oh real yeah you know uh I mean you
could say killed you could say quickly
barbecued but I'll say this man thank
you guys for your service right
they're um baritone what was the other
guy's name Anthony yes shout-out to both
of them that's coolest video we've ever
got hand grenades bring them back
brother
I say give everybody one it stopped
these school shootings if we're launched
some hang grenades you know I'm saying
OD first of all the bat the toughest kid
in school should get one grenade cuz
that kid is gonna like oh there's a
shooting going on let me roll this [ __ ]
down the hall here's the other thing
that I was surprised by it I was
surprised how long those grenades took
the actually explode that's how they
trick you that took way longer than I
thought
because you're less sometime to run well
you're like the guy that dies on that
movie with the cartoon with the mom with
the wolf you talking about the
roadrunner yeah because you think that
it should have gone off you walk back
over to read on the side of the handle
though wonder whether student goooo
boom BAM deceased boy but thank you guys
man I'll say this hand grenades bring
her back
yeah yeah Angra days bring her back nice
last one guys [ __ ] salute me dude Gino
Garcia from Chicago sup do sup Brennan I
got a king under stinky here for you
guys [ __ ] at your girlfriend's house
personally I feel uncomfortable with it
but when [ __ ] needs to go down she needs
to go down so tell me what you guys
think King under sting it can't be
[ __ ] paint your girl's toilet brown
man
there's nothing least sex and then
blowing up your girl's bathroom I used
to hold it for hours and pretend I
needed gas even though I had a bike oh
yeah but I better go pick some things up
and just go blow up a Conoco winners
come and do your talking white walkers
I'm talking about autumn is coming from
the brown walkers I'll walk you got a
hold that sucker in baby Cleveland
Browns are at the gate bro you ate it
you hold it that's my motto
you don't [ __ ] it somebody else's house
it's disrespectful that is psychopath
her mom lives there bro here's the thing
all day you're driving around
when that's doing that you're gonna go
to your lady's house do some sort of
[ __ ] psycho all day who are you
Rick Rude bro kind of animal does that
his girl's house man yeah who are you
Larry shitman get it together boy if I
can definitely sting that yeah dude you
got a car dude you know what I'm saying
hanging like nine air fresheners in a
trunk and [ __ ] in the trunk on a canvas
or something like Joey Diaz would do it
like a gentleman yeah [ __ ] out the car
window
that's crazy or an idiot better show you
girls good point that's it we did it bro
we did it it freakin did it dude shout
to the grenade launchers that's the
grenade launcher do you listen that girl
that picture No yeah I did do I'll see
what happens we will see what happens
young trying to help you out I know man
but again dude I will do that for you
I'm your genie whatever you need ask me
yeah I got you dude nah man like I said
I wish I had a friend like me um three
wishes to definitely never come true God
beer genie in a heartbeat and you'd be
in an Igloo cooler instead of a lamp
doesn't that stupid ass lamp that's a
good point actually
I'll wait right there have a real ass
gene in an Igloo cooler man
I like stretch my legs yeah bro all
right thank you guys for being here on
this episode of King and this thing is
that new merch you got new merch dog new
king of the sting and we got hats this
we got our jerseys on there just drop
that's beautiful man check him out get
your tees uh on the offspring that's
what it's gonna be
hey-oh spring is like breathing thank
you everybody for your submissions we
really appreciate it
send them send more that's how the show
goes the best one you said make the show
man I'm off to Calgary and brea Calgary
Yuk Yuk's June 2020 second and then Brea
Brea improv dog it's like bread it's
almost like that word bread but without
the D right Brad get him and also I will
be in Vancouver
this week Oh theatre right yep vogue
Theatre Thursday night and then the
other place that I'm gonna be coming up
I'm in Tulsa Oklahoma on June 27 our
Austin Texas on June 27 in Tulsa
Oklahoma on June 28 and I'm in some
other places too but but the tickets
aren't available anymore so looking
forward to seeing you guys we've also
talked about maybe next year doing a
king in the sting trying to see we get
together on stage I think we might try a
king the sting live at The Comedy Store
in July maybe it'd be interesting huh
feel about bro yeah all right man see
myself do ya thang
[Music]